two days ago I got an email sadly
announcing the death of Neil Bartlett
who's the scientist who's probably done
most for the chemistry of xenon since it
was first discovered at the end of the
19th century
so in the balloon we've got a sample of
xenon now xenon is one of the inert
gases but it's one of the inert gases
that's right the way down the bottom end
period so it's really really dense so
what that means is that the gas
molecules themselves are really really
large really really heavy
so in principle they'll sink near
Bartlett discovered that xenon which
everyone had thought was a completely
inert element had really could form
reactions and could form compounds
something that nobody thought was
possible until then and this took place
in the early 1960s and I've got a
picture here of his iconic experiment he
did his experiment I think in late 1962
and perhaps early 63 and this was
published just over a year later and
these are to expect
pictures this is the experiment before
and after so we've done an experiment
here we filled this building with xenon
now xenon is very expensive so there's
about 40 pounds with a xenon in this
balloon right now yeah so we're going to
do this experiment and we're going to
see if it sinks and I think you agree
that it does sink quite quickly what he
did was he took a glass bulb of a
compound of platinum platinum
hexafluoride PT f6 which is a gas now
that's quite unusual to have a metal
compound that's a gas but it's rather a
nice bright orange gas and he put
together a piece of equipment here where
in this tube here there is xenon gas
which is colorless and this is a magnet
which can be lifted up and break a tiny
seal so that the two gases can mix but
just to show you how dense it is we've
got a similar balloon but you'll notice
in this balloon is much much higher
filled so it's much much bigger now this
is one that we've just blown up with air
so now what had happened was before this
experiment was done with xenon that one
of Neal's students had discovered that
platinum hexafluoride reacted with
oxygen in air
to form a compound in which one electron
had run been removed from the oxygen to
make au 2 plus and this was a solid
material
it was itself quite a surprising
reaction now what Neil did was that he
looked at the periodic table and
wondered which other elements required
about the same amount of energy as
oxygen to remove one electron and he
came up with xenon so he tried this
experiment using the apparatus here they
lifted this magnet or he lifted this
magnet it crashed down the xenon rushed
in and suddenly this red gas was turned
into a yellow solid in fact it turned
out he was doing this experiment with
his student but the student whose name
I've forgotten had to go home so Neil
did this experiment by himself and he
was very late getting home for his
dinner and his wife according to him on
this video was really very angry but
chemistry had been transformed well this
experiment was voted by American chemist
as one of the top 10 most important
chemical experiments that had been done
in the 20th century so let's see if we
can compare the rates at which these two
balloons will sink so we can look at the
comparative densities ready xenon exists
in the air and when people liquefy air
they first all separate the nitrogen and
then the oxygen for and at the end
they're left with the noble gases argon
Krypton and xenon so it is made from the
air and one of the problems with this
price rise of xenon was that at the same
time as there was a bigger demand for
xenon there was a downturn in the
steelmaking industry which uses a lot of
oxygen so the chemical plants that were
or the refrigeration plants that were
making zeenat oxygen were switched off
so there was a small
supply of xenon whoa that'll be the air
this is an old-fashioned xenon lamp the
xenon in its innards bulb and you put a
large voltage through here and the xenon
gets very hot and shines out as a very
bright light it looks black here because
the electrodes get so hot that the metal
has evaporated but xenon itself is
colorless this is a more modern xenon
lamp of the sort of lamp that is used in
very powerful spotlights for example on
tanks to illuminate those military tanks
to illuminate the target and the window
here is made of aluminium oxide and all
the light comes out as a really very
powerful beam